so what else did you do this weekend it
was a big Sports weekend Oh I went and
exchanged my Christmas tree exchanged
it
why we bought it and after like two days
it was dying oh really we we was
drinking water which is weird CU
normally it doesn't drink
water according to the internet M if
it's dying but it was just dying and we
sent them pictures and we felt weird
about it returning it yeah cuz something
you know a lot of times Le and I are
just like yeah whatever but like this
thing is kind of dead and it's going to
turn into a fire hazard in some days but
we felt validated cuz we sent them
pictures and they were like oh yeah
bring that back okay um so you know
put the truck to work
nice nice what was really funny was when
we picked up the first tree the first
guy we had helping us he didn't give a
at all yeah yeah he he tied one
string and like like in my truck and the
first time I took it home and left the
bed open he tied one string around the
top of an 8ft tree and he was
like yeah that's good he just walked
away I walked this other I like can I
get some more string secure that
myself nice like the blue collar guy
that I am yeah you're tough as
Nails D I'm tough as nails dude I should
be on the show I got I got to set up a
Christmas tree dude you're I know dude
no it's only the fifth 20 more days
there is and I got Christmas lights all
over my place you're going to go fake
light fake tree or real tree I think we
have a fake one that we usually you
should go fake cuz there's a Christmas
tree shortage this year is there there
is okay so you're saying I should go
fake to like give to let other families
have them no I'm saying there's not many
left oh you're just saying it'd be
difficult to get one I see yeah you've
missed the rush yeah okay sorry
pal yeah not so uh buying a real
Christmas tree is not just whenever you
want it okay yeah see that's the type of
that we got it's sad where'd you
find this picture just on
online can you look up sad depressing
Christmas tree literally she did
Christmas tree yeah got the tree we had
uh you know decorated that hoe takes
time yeah I here's the thing
Elina I'll let her decorate 90% of it
most years
okay I felt like such a dick cuz this
year I finally after a couple years not
I finally but we haven't doing the
Christmas tree thing super long but only
five years but every year like there's
been a transition right so this year as
I'm putting up all the ornaments I don't
recognize half of them and I go what the
she's like I've just kind of picked
them up and I'm kind of recognizing some
and I'm
realizing all the ornaments have like
meaning now okay like they're not it's
not cuz when we first started doing the
tree it was just you know 40 balls of
silver yeah now I like I'm crying as I'm
putting this up you know CU like I
proposed her in Joshua Tree so she got
these like porcelain Cactus and we had
s'mores after so then she found like a
oneof one s'more ornament it's like kind
of discreet and they're all like color
matched and Allie's first Christmas bone
and I'm just like putting I'm like and
when we get this one she's like oh we
got you last I bought that one 6 months
ago I bought this one 2 weeks ago and
now the tree is like a story of our
life that's so nice yeah that really is
but we're yeah you know
yeah same with same with us we
we had a we took like pregnancy
photos hell yeah you do the hand on the
tummy oh yeah I did the whole thing I
didn't you know both of us were
like we don't want these to be cheesy
like the rest of them yeah and then the
photographer was like look away from the
camera and smile I like gladly
you know what I mean like I just did
everything that you're not like you're
not supposed to do if you don't want
them to be cheesy yeah like she was like
now uh put your hand on the stomach I
was like it's already there and then
we're doing the where I'm like
leaning down like kissing her F her head
and she's like looking up at me and
like that I'm like this feels awesome
and then I I went down and I kissed her
stomach you did the Drake yeah yeah I
did yeah without the photographer asking
for it
that's funny I just went and did it and
so and she got the picture she's
shooting on film so a lot of them are
like out of focus and weird and then or
no they were all really good but I'm
just saying it was like hard to get a
really great shot and the one that
turned out like perfectly was this just
me down there like kissing the stomach
so we showed somebody and they're like
oh that's cute and Kel was like yeah she
didn't ask for that Cody just did
[Laughter]
it it's funny just an animal in its
environment just yeah
this man uh just had awful
imagery why don't you goe down and kiss
the stomach yeah
sure oh
Jesus yeah that's the that's the cliche
shot is licking the stomach
yeah just like dropping your T like is
yeah yeah
yeah no they were they were they turned
out really really good but I was
thinking the same thing I was looking at
these pictures and I'm like these are so
they they're amazing they're cool cuz
like being shot on film they don't end
up looking as like corny as they
normally do you should post all of them
in a massive Carousel for the public to
watch I probably will end up doing that
honestly because like this what I'm
saying some of them I'm like doing the
cliche and I'm looking at these
photos like this is so nice I
can't wait to frame this and put this up
in our place well so then now you got to
one up it what got do the naked version
The Naked weird ones where you're like
in oil and strange backdrop and what are
those I've never seen those you've never
seen like ult weird naked pregnancy
where are you looking it's Facebook no
I've never seen that did you search that
oh like that nah I've seen
weirder that's like
funny the ones I'm thinking of are just
like kind of naked and
off-putting it's like both are
naked so why don't you go ahead and
search naked pregnancy shoot yeah
yeah yeah what about Tastefully nude
prenatal
photos Tastefully nude oiled up prenatal
photos do you need oiled up N I need it
no no it's
fine safe search yeah foiled
again I'm just saying they exist like
the weird naked ones okay I believe you
look at look at at that one go up one go
up one row and to the right one more
like that one what the what's happening
there exactly that's what I mean or also
right above
it yeah yeah yeah maximize that
one yeah punch in heart no she's not
naked enhance enhance
enhance the dress is wild yeah a
lot of them are weird yeah I
mean I get it you know
know it's a special moment yeah you have
an idea and then you go to execute and
you're like well maybe it didn't hit
right I I understand I understand the
attempt it's funny how some of them turn
out yeah yeah like some of some of these
are I get that it's supposed to
highlight the pregnancy but some of them
just just look really sexualized it's
very odd yeah that's
true yeah a lot of the people go like
like super artsy too it's like it's not
really that artsy like I yeah sorry I
just have a distinct memory of a girl I
went to elementary school with and she
posted her pregnancy photos this was she
got pregnant super young and it was her
butt ass naked on a brown
backdrop just
like you know not a lot of coverage and
you're like this is a n this is like a
nude yeah yeah this is something
pregnant this is something my sweet
waterer WAP would send me yeah yeah yeah
I was thinking that at the time you know
I was super young but when I think about
that now I'm like oh this is like a
sweet
waterf water yeah so yeah that I'm just
saying that's the next step yeah if
people like criticize it they're like
this is corny you're like all right all
right okay yeah you think that's corny
yeah know this is ours were very normal
compared to all that the only one
that was kind of bordering on it was one
of them down kissing her
stomach yeah exactly and she was like
okay oh oh we're doing this okay I was
like we are we are doing this I got very
into
[Laughter]
it